so somebody goes Ali dawa leave my
people alone
leave somalis alone
[Music]
um
I mean we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah
oh yes brother Ali what kind you speak
in Somali well I'm going to be dropping
more of these balls as the video carries
on why am I doing this video this is a
video directly to my beloved Somali
brothers and sisters but before we do
that what is this video about so I did a
video a couple of days ago called Somali
these Asians on divorced women
now I was digging up the Somali
Community why because it's one of the
things that I love about the community
which is what that they don't look down
on divorces that when a woman a Somali
woman is divorced the community doesn't
shun her look down up on her or make you
feel like she's some kind of rubbish
however sadly with the Asian community
that wasn't the case so in the video I
clearly pick up the Somali Community
I've I've seen that with the Asian
Community Etc this concept with the
Somali Community like personally myself
I've realized that they don't frown upon
divorces like they don't like this it's
like it's come like a married divorcee
you don't see that with the Somali
Community like from what I've seen like
with the Asians I have seen it okay
alhamdulillah and I criticize and gives
them a certain Asian Community however
for some odd reasons we had the Somali
Community a lot of people saying some
positive stuff for example somebody
commented and said as they eat Somali
divorce woman it is not Taboo in our
culture women are necessary women are
not necessarily always the wrong in
divorces so why should we blame them
another person said being a divorce
isn't something ashamed in Somali KOJA
and Somali Somali women have no issue
remarrying after a divorce and that's
what my point was but for some odd
reason in the comments section for some
odd reason going on a mad one with
myself why is obsessed with some other
community why'd you always have to
mention us do you do it for Chris you're
doing it for likes and this and that and
I'm thinking to myself what did I say so
bad and why is this assumption as if I
have a problem with the Somali Community
I have no problem with somal community
so I'm putting everything to the side
I'm a Muslim but sometimes when I see
these comments it makes me want to shout
out
foreign
[Music]
yes I mean I've I've had enough I mean
what's going on here as a panel artists
speak Somali to get the communication to
you guys my dear Somali brothers and
sisters look
I've planned many videos before Etc and
I've never ever ever spoken into the
Somali community so the question is in
this specific video I'm criticizing the
Asian Community but I've got tamales who
are upset when I'm praising them and
seeing a good quality that the Somali
Community have amongst many
alhamdulillah you know known for the
Quran as well so let's read some of
these comments and understand what on
Earth are they talking about so somebody
goes Ali dawa leave my people alone
leave somalis alone you talk on my
community and don't invite my people yes
my people because I'm Somali and you're
not you always seem to be coming for
Somali people so basically in a nutshell
he's saying for the love of God who can
take this man away now please I would
like anybody to point out a single time
I have ever spoken negatively on any
Community or said a bad word
specifically somalis when now there's
many more comments let's read through
them look somebody at least they
understood the video they watched the
video Ali dawa represented Somali
Community okay then somebody goes why
bring somalis up there's no there's no
Somali person there why the hell do I
need a Somali person there when I am
talking good over the Somali Community
it wasn't like a discussion about the
Somali culture and I'm like yeah let's
talk about it is no so what's the point
it was just one statement that was made
so I don't understand why people are
bugging out that's why you guys make me
say
yo I'm tired leave me alone what is it
and this is not old this is some of you
guys to find Allah I'm just saying guys
the more you guys behave like this and
the more you don't even watch the video
most of these comments multiple of them
why is there not some other person on
the panel why Somali person on the panel
the discussion is not even about somalis
all it was was one specific comment that
I said I saw something positive that is
it now the more you do that and this
goes to any community Asian Somali
Pakistani Bengali Eritrean whatever it
may be whatever it is guys the more you
guys behave like this it just shows you
guys to be insecure there is nothing
negative said about it now I know this
all ties back to one specific issue
which is in my marriage documentary me
pursuing marriage with a Somali sister
that didn't happen because the family
not family the uncle wasn't allowing it
that's it it's not that deep that was
just my story this happened to me with
the Bengali Community it happened to me
with the Pakistani Community it even
happened to me with the Eritrean
community and I talk about that in my
marriage documentary this is just my
journey that I am talking to people does
this mean every Somali Community is like
that or everyone in Somali in the
community is like that no of course not
this is specific story and people have
this perception as if I wanted to marry
her and she said no and I was chasing
her are you guys really thinking I'm
going to mention something that makes me
look so bad no it was mutually we wanted
to get married we wasn't in love I would
be like nothing like that it was just a
Islamic shared proposal in an Islamic
way which didn't go ahead and that's it
chapter clothes it's not that deep I'm
just mentioning the story to learn a
lesson from it and I mentioned different
sisters that was getting to know for
marriage similar things happened it's
just that's it so people think that I'm
still hung up on that look I'm married
I've moved on long time ago so guys
please the specific Somali Community
just know I have never had any ill
feelings ever this happened to me with
different communities none of them I
speak ill of why because it happens it's
cultural tribalism whatever it may be
okay it happens it's fine but please get
rid of this notion that I am hung up on
something that happened time ago and I'm
trying to get revenge I'm not Petty I'm
not a child okay these discussions will
happen and guess what on the bitter
truth show soon we will be having a
group of panel from different cultures
we want to get the somalis we want to
get the algerians we want to get the
Moroccans want to get the Turks want to
get the Kurds and talk about cultural
the cultural aspects of marriage divorce
looking to get married in those cultures
you can apply at the bitter truth the
bittertruthshot gmail.com and I think
that's all I wanted to say guys so I
hope that is clear and for those who is
not clear let me articulate it in a
different way
foreign
[Music]